تقول روسيا كما كنا
نقول إنها تخطط بالفعل لبدء
تجارب جماعية في أقرب وقت في الأسبوع المقبل
بعد نشر دراسة عن
لقاحها الطمع ، تقول النتائج إنها قد
ولّدت بالفعل استجابة مناعية في المرحلة الأولى
والثانية من تجاربها في المرحلة الثالثة  على الرغم من
أنه لم يكتمل بعد بشكل جيد ، فإن ضيفي التالي
هو رئيس تحرير مجلة لانسيت حيث
تم نشر هذه النتائج الأخيرة ريتشارد
هورتون وانضم إلي الآن
من لندن ويسعدني أن تكون
معنا يا سيدي لجمهورنا في المنزل ، هل
لدينا رغبة  لقاح ، هل يمكننا أن نقول أنه الآن
لا يمكننا القول إن لدينا
لقاحًا جاهزًا للاستخدام العام على نطاق
واسع ، ما يمكننا قوله هو أن
هذا
اللقاح الروسي الجديد النتائج
مشجعة
ولكن سيكون من السابق لأوانه أو سابق
لأوانه الاعتقاد بأن هذا هو اللقاح الروسي الجديد  أساس
لقاح ناجح
للاستخدام العام ، لماذا كان السبب السابق
لأوانه في أن هذه دراسة صغيرة جدًا ،
يقارن 76 متطوعًا فقط ذلك
بدراسة لقاح أكسفورد التي نشرناها
قبل أسبوع واحد فقط  قبل ذلك كان أكثر من ألف
مشارك ،
لذا فهذه دراسة صغيرة ، ما ثبت
بوضوح أن اللقاح يثير بالتأكيد
الاستجابة المناعية التي تريدها أن
تثير استجابة قوية
جدًا واستنادًا إلى هؤلاء 76
مشاركًا حتى الآن اللقاح  يبدو
أنها
آمنة وخالية من أي آثار ضارة خطيرة ،
ولكن كما قلت للتو ، نحن بحاجة الآن إلى هذه
التجارب العشوائية واسعة النطاق ، دراسات المرحلة الثالثة
وهي مستمرة ،
فهي مستمرة في حوالي 40 ألف
مشارك بدأوا بالفعل في
موسكو ونحن بحاجة  أن ننتظر
نتائج تلك الدراسات قبل أن
نقول أي شيء أكثر تحديدا ، لقد
أوضحت النقطة في وقت سابق في هذا العرض أم
أن كبرياء أمة ليس في استعراض
للقوة العسكرية أو
كشف النقاب عن متراصة أه هذه
الأيام أه بدلا من ذلك  يبدو أنها
نتائج تجربة طبية ، ما
مدى قلقك بشأن ما
يبدو أنه يستعد ليكون هذا السباق
ليكون الأول ، نعم ،
أعني أنني استمعت إلى الإحاطة الإعلامية
التي عقدت
أه  اليوم بعد ظهر هذا اليوم في موسكو
وكان ذلك مؤسفًا على ما أعتقد
لأن الطريقة التي تم بها
تقديم النتائج كانت بمثابة تحدٍ
للعلم الغربي ، حيث قال المقدمون إنهم
تلقوا الكثير من الانتقادات ، وكان هذا
ردًا على الانتقادات
بأن لقاحهم كان أفضل  من
لقاح أسترازينيكا
، وكان الأمر متروكًا الآن لأسترازينيكا
والعلماء الغربيين للإجابة على
مواطنيهم وأعتقد أنه إذا بدأنا في وضع
دولة ضد
لقاح ضد شركة لقاح ضد شركة لقاح
ضد الشركة ، فسيؤدي ذلك تمامًا
إلى
تقويض أي نوع من الاستجابة العقلانية ،
فهذه  أزمة عالمية بسبب
أزمة عالمية تحتاج إلى استجابة
عالمية وحل عالمي ،
نريد الكثير من اللقاحات
التي ستدخل في المرحلة الثالثة من التجارب
لأن بعضها سينجح
والبعض الآخر سيفشل ،
لكن هذه ليست حربًا بين البلدان
هذه  يجب أن يكون حول التعاون ، لذا
أعتقد أنه من المؤسف أن الطريقة التي تم
تقديمها بها اليوم